the help and support
we have received over these past few
months has meant more than words can say
from family and friends to complete
strangers
across the country and the world
thank you
Nikki and Paul's girls have already
taken great comfort in a deeply
thoughtful gift
sent to them in Goodwill
and in time they will read the many
cards which are filled with such
kindness and love
sadly we feel the need to again raise
and address the issue of social media
It's upsetting that we've continued to
receive
negative targeted messages
and still wildly inaccurate speculation
being shared on numerous platforms
we encourage people
to look at the facts
the evidence which is being heard during
the inquest
and the conclusion reached by the
coroner
to ignore any amateur views and opinions
and be mindful of the of the impact the
words bring
we want to formally say thank you for
the support and compassion
showed by Lankershim constabury
is Majesty's coroner Dr edley
his team
Sophie Cartwright KC of Dean support
Chambers and Terry Wilcock to put your
solicitors
we now need to be allowed time to
comprehend all of the events leading up
to this day
we ask that you will respect our privacy
and this time to let us rebuild and take
time to heal thank you
I want to start by saying that first and
foremost my thoughts today are with
Nikki's family and loved ones they have
been through the most unimaginable
ordeal over the last six months
and I can only hope that this inquest in
some way will help by answering some of
the questions that they are they had
about what happened to Nikki on the
January the 27th and will allow them to
start the process of rebuilding their
lives as best they can
I would like to thank Dr rodely for his
careful consideration of the evidence
presented at this inquest as well as
legal counsel and all of the witnesses
for their participation
I hope that his Majesty's Coroner's
clear and definitive findings will put
an end to ill-informed speculation and
conspiracy theories which have been so
damaging to Nikki's family and the
community of Saint Michael's
I would like to finish by bringing this
back to Nikki
she was clearly a much-loved mum partner
daughter sister and friend and I would
once again like to express my deepest
sympathy to all her loved ones
and I would ask that their privacy is
respected at this time to allow them the
time and space to rebuild and to heal
thank you